and the Oscar for Best Performance by an
actor in a supporting role goes to Jack
Palance
Billy Crystal God I crap bigger on him
uh
you know there are times when when you
reach a certain age plateau where the
the producers say they talk about you
and they say well what do you think and
we risk it can we do it can we use them
the other guy says I don't know let's
elect some younger ones will you make
them look older but this one you know
it's it's kind of difficult they forget
they forget to ask that you go out there
and you do all these things like for
instance you know you go out there
well that's that's that's nothing really
as far as the 200 push-ups you can do
that all night and that doesn't make any
difference whether she's there or not
because and besides it's a hell of a lot
less expensive Wow
you know a long time ago 1949 first
picture 1949 first film I've been
shooting about two weeks and the the
producer came to me he said Jack my name
at that time was allowed the meal but he
called me Jack uh he says Jack you're
gonna win the Academy Award can you
believe it
42 years later was right how this son of
a [ __ ] hill